registered voters in the Seattle area
just had the chance to participate in
what officials say is the country's most
extensive use of mobile voting yet over
95 percent of the elections ballots were
submitted electronically via app or
website supporters of mobile voting say
if you let people cast their ballots on
their phones they're a lot more likely
to do it because it'll be easier and
take less time but some experts warn
that voting on our phones creates new
privacy and security problems that we
don't have solutions for will it always
be too risky for a presidential election
or is nationwide mobile voting only a
matter of time at the end of the day
voting software is still software and
all software is buggy and there will
always be errors in security holes it's
impossible to build perfect software a
tech company called democracy Live built
the system that Washington voters used
during the recent pilot and while
democracy live agrees that both software
and humans can be foul ball they're
confident their system is still safer
than some methods currently in use King
County which is Washington State's most
populous county recently allowed mobile
voting for over 1 million voters in a
small local election voters could use
their phones or their laptops to log on
to a portal open up a ballot and then
they could choose to submit that ballot
electronically which is what we would
think of as mobile voting supporters of
mobile voting say that it will make the
process more convenient and boost voter
turnout in King County election
officials say that turnout this year was
double what it was for this election
last year most of the roughly 6,500
ballots were submitted electronically
only 209 were submitted by mail or
Dropbox if I have to choose between
submitting a paper ballot or using the
app on my phone
I actually would do the paper ballot we
have a lot of experience with paper
ballots over time and so there's kind of
a big field test out there that's been
going on for decades and we know that
it's not
need to change a large number of paper
ballots my concern about the digital
environment is that once those votes are
collected in a single database the
possibility that someone could
manipulate a large number of votes at
once is much higher even more
importantly is the fact that other
people would potentially fear that that
would happen even under the best
circumstances introducing new election
technology can add a new layer of doubt
to results in Iowa's caucuses the state
Democratic Party wanted to use an app to
collect and report results because they
thought it would make it faster and
easier unfortunately based on our
reporting the app wasn't put through
enough testing and there wasn't enough
planning so it ended up having glitches
that have really caused problems for
figuring out what the results were in
Iowa there was a sense that maybe it
just didn't work the way it was supposed
to work and just introducing that amount
of doubt into the system D legitimizes
people's confidence in the vote and it
doesn't I think give people a high level
of confidence that we can manage this
sort of digital layer on top of what is
already a pretty emotionally fraught
voting system advocates are worrying
after what happened in Iowa that people
start to be scared of using new
technology for voting supporters of
mobile voting say they focus on security
they plan in advance and that they don't
think what happened with I was I should
have a negative impact on their separate
efforts running an end-to-end test is
crucial in most software development
creating software for smartphones
presents a unique challenge when it
comes to testing which is especially
important when creating voting
technology we're building it so that it
can run on all the thousands of possible
combinations of Android phones and iOS
phones and even Microsoft phones and
phones whose operating system haven't
been updated in 3 or 4 years or even
more and so there's almost
a limitless number of environments in
which you have to prove that software
can work and it's almost impossible to
test it in all those environments except
in an actual election still mobile
voting supporters say it's important to
find ways to improve access and engage
voters some experts and some people who
advocate for mobile bodings say it's
inevitable they say that you know
younger generations are used to doing
everything on their phones and they want
to meet voters where they are maybe when
every single car on the road is driven
by a robot and a generation of people
can't even imagine that a human being
would have ever driven a car will also
be saying God can you imagine that
people used to vote on pieces of paper I
can see that coming and I think will be
there but I think it's 20 years not 10